brigitte est ce que tu as quelque chose
à te reprocher à n'ont rien du tout
vraiment l époque où tu faisais des
films x tu avais l'impression de
commettre des péchés utiliser un travail
tu prenais ça comme un jeu
en fait je crois que j'ai compris ce que
j'avais fait après sur le moment j'étais
j'étais très jeune et il a une sorte de
naïveté d'inconscience et
et je vivais je vivais les choses comme
comme aujourd'hui d'ailleurs quand tu
m'as pris conscience de ce que tu avais
fais ce que tu vas regretter je me suis
empêchée de le regretter parce que leur
gré
peut amener la culpabilité et peut donc
nous écrire elle peut donc nous casser
des autres donc je me suis empêchée de
le regretter
c'était à refaire mais je crois qu'il ya
certaines choses que je ne leur ferai
plus mais changera pas tant de choses
que ça je crois qui je me suis un peu
trop un peu trop donner un peu trop
gaspiller et
je suis pas sûr aujourd'hui d'avoir
réussi à effacer tout ça il ya des
cicatrices qui sont quand même pas tout
à fait refermée et qui se referme ont
sans doute jamais quels sont tes table
les tabou l'inceste évidemment parce que
parce que l'enfant l'enfant n'est pas en
droit de savoir ce qu'il a ce qui lasse
il a besoin ce qu'il a envie
le racisme je crois qu'il ya beaucoup de
choses qui se font pas raciste mais qui
sont qui sont dramatiques
mais j'ai pas beaucoup de tabous non
parce que tu crois en deux et pour être
sûr de ne rien rater de linars dit tu es
abonné vous mettez un pouce bleus